Welcome back, SCP Explained viewers!
We hope you're all having a terrible day-
I'm sorry, my mistake.
I meant, we hope you're all having a wonderful
day!
That unfortunate linguistic mixup was brought
on by a force we're still struggling to understand.
You see, we here at SCP Explained have fallen
under the influence of a temporal anomaly
commonly referred to as "Opposite Day."
You might be under the impression that Opposite
Day is just something elementary school children
came up with to excuse walking backwards and
saying things they don't mean, but you would
be sorely mistaken.
It is all too real, and no one is immune to
its confusing effects!
In the spirit of Opposite Day, which comes
for us all no matter how much we try to prepare,
we decided to fire up the good old Anom-O-Tron
6000 to see how this unknowable force might
impact one of the anomalies at the SCP Foundation!
We all know what happens in the ordinary,
non-Opposite world when someone looks at SCP-096's
face.
It's one of the first rules they tell new
employees at the SCP Foundation: don't look
at the Shy Guy's face!
But what if the effect was reversed?
What if seeing SCP-096's face didn't send
the creature into an irrepressible murderous
rage, but rather inspired that same mindless
violence in the ordinary person that saw it?
Let's start the simulation and find out.
Imagine, if you can, a world in which the
SCP Foundation did not have SCP-096 in containment,
or even know of its existence.
It's difficult to envision a creature nearly
synonymous with the Foundation itself living
a life outside of those reinforced concrete
and steel walls, but that is the world in
which our story begins.
Deep in the snow-covered forests of a remote
mountain range, a long-limbed, pale, humanoid
creature ran through the trees with innocent
abandon.
Its white skin and long, thin arms and legs
allowed it to blend in with the snow and the
narrow trunks of the trees, providing a natural
camouflage from any interlopers that might
present a threat.
The creature lived a largely peaceful existence,
feeding on roots, berries, and, yes, some
of the local wildlife, but that's just the
way things work in nature.
There are predators and prey, none good or
evil in the way human beings conceive of things,
all just doing their best to stay alive.
The creature that does not think of itself
as SCP-096 had known little more than the
life it lived in this forest, keeping itself
hidden from view whenever hikers or explorers
happened upon its domain.
It couldn't be sure what would happen if it
was found, but its instincts drove the creature
to avoid detection at all costs.
But there is no way to guarantee perfect safety
in this world, and, as it so often does, one
day something went wrong.
Exhausted from searching for food all day
and night, the creature decided to get some
rest, leaning its head against a sturdy tree
trunk and closing its eyes for a little while.
It did not fall asleep, the creature wasn't
capable of sleep the way humans might think
of it, but it did allow its mind to wander
and its alertness to slip.
It let down its guard, only for a moment...but
that was one moment too many.
That was just enough time for its keen ears
to miss the sound of approaching footsteps,
muffled slightly by the thick blanket of snow
covering the ground.
By the time it heard one of the hikers speak,
it was too late.
"What is that?!"
"I'm not sure...should we get a closer look?"
The creature opened its eyes to find two strangers,
a man and a woman clad in heavy winter coats
and hiking gear, standing just a few feet
away.
It turned reflexively toward the sound, and
the strangers' eyes fell upon its face.
All of a sudden, their expressions changed,
from apprehension and curiosity to a twisted
scowl, a mix of fear, pain, and animalistic
rage.
The hikers each let out a primal scream and
descended on the creature, attacking it with
whatever they had on hand.
The woman clawed at its face with her fingernails,
and the man pulled the heavy backpack from
his shoulders and began to hit the creature
with it again and again.
The creature was far bigger, and far stronger,
than these two strangers, and it fought back
in an attempt to defend itself.
It swung its massive arms at the hikers, sending
them flying in opposite directions.
The woman collided with a tree, her head hitting
wood with a loud crack!
The man flew out of sight, disappearing over
the edge of a cliff.
The creature hadn't intended to hurt them,
only to keep itself safe.
As the Shy Guy began to feel a pang of guilt
for the first time in its life, it heard that
horrible scream again.
The woman had regained consciousness and was
resuming her attack in full force, blood dripping
from her nose and ears and staining the white
snow red.
If the Shy Guy was able to speak, it would
have said "Why are you doing this?
Please, stop, I don't want to hurt you!"
But it couldn't say a word, so instead, it
decided to try and outrun the woman instead.
It turned, and began to tear through the forest
at a swift, unnatural gait, as the woman's
screams faded away into the distance.
As the Shy Guy had suspected, she could not
keep up with its inhuman speed, especially
not with the injuries she had sustained during
the fight.
But what had happened?
Why had she and the man with her flown into
such a violent rage?
Something about the sight of the creature's
face had set them off.
It had avoided detection for so long, but
it had gotten sloppy, and now its home was
no longer safe.
There was no time to rest, the creature would
have to find another safe place to hide out,
and soon.
The last thing it wanted was another confrontation
with a stranger who would look at its face
and then erupt into violence.
As the creature continued to run, leaving
the thick cover of the treeline and making
its way down the mountain, it wondered: would
anyone who saw its face react the same way?
Perhaps this was just a uniquely awful case,
perhaps this wouldn't happen again.
Still, it would be best to stay out of sight.
Better safe than sorry.
Of course, the creature not yet known as SCP-096
had never heard that expression, living a
completely solitary life void of any idioms
or classic sayings.
But, its feelings vis a vis safety and regret
were pretty much the same.
The creature descended the treacherous mountain,
effortlessly navigating the unforgiven rocky
surface and deadly slicks of ice.
By the time the creature had left its old
mountain home behind, the sun had set and
night had fallen on the wintery landscape.
It slowed its stride then, listening for the
sounds of approaching potential threats, but
there appeared to be no one around.
It was just the lone pale creature, the moon
peeking out from between the clouds, and the
open unknown world ahead.
After some time walking completely alone,
the creature spotted lights up ahead.
It didn't understand the concept of a town,
but that was indeed what it was.
The creature swerved away from the majority
of the lights, and stumbled upon an old wooden
barn, apparently abandoned and left to rot
in the elements.
This would be as good a place as any to rest
for a little while, to shelter from the incoming
snowstorm and stay out of sight.
So, the Shy Guy made itself a makeshift bed
of straw, and curled up there to wait out
the night.
As it lay there, thinking about the day before,
it felt a sudden wave of grief for its lost
home, for the changes that had come into its
life unbidden and turned it all upside down.
The creature covered its face with its massive
hands, and began to weep.
The creature was startled from its tears when
morning came, and with it, the sound of someone
breaking down the rotting wood beams that
lined the barn walls.
It stood, looking toward the sound, and saw
the woman from the mountain, pale and shivering,
eyes rimmed with dark circles and face caked
in dried blood.
She still screamed that horrible scream, tearing
away at the wood even as it ripped up the
flesh of her hands.
She was missing one boot, and her coat was
torn open, scattering tiny feathers with every
movement.
She did not appear to feel the cold, the pain,
the exhaustion of chasing the creature for
so long.
She only wanted one thing, to destroy the
creature by any means necessary.
With a screech like a banshee, she leapt onto
the creature's back, clawing at its face and
eyes.
It thrashed wildly, throwing the woman to
the ground, and running without a glance back.
Maybe she survived her fall onto the cold
hard ground, or maybe it would be the blow
that actuallly finished her off.
The creature's only priority was to keep moving
before something else tried to attack.
What the creature didn't know was that the
citizens of the nearby town, the one that
it was about to run right into the center
of in its panic, were gathering to celebrate
their annual Christmas festival, complete
with an early-morning parade through the town
square.
The same town square that the Shy Guy was
bounding into at that exact moment.
As the Shy Guy raced over the cobblestone
street, it ran directly into the line of sight
of a full marching band, a fleet of dancers
dressed in costumes inspired by The 12 Days
of Christmas, a row of young women competing
in the Miss Holiday Spirit pageant, and a
jolly old man dressed up as Santa Claus in
his sleigh.
The marching band saw the creature first,
terror morphing quickly into that same wordless
rage as their eyes fell on its face.
It moved to cover itself, to hide its face
from view, but it was too late.
The marching band swarmed around it, swinging
trombones and clarinets.
One percussion player broke a massive bass
drum over the creature's head in the struggle.
Still, it was able to withstand the musical
onslaught, flinging musicians this way and
that, snapping brass instruments like twigs
and crushing woodwinds into mulch.
Unfortunately, as the marching band was being
dealt with, the commotion had drawn the attention
of the dancers and the pageant competitors.
One swarm was replaced with two more as the
performers flew into a frenzy, tackling the
creature to the ground and using every item
at their disposal to try and harm it.
The creature bellowed with fear and frustration,
prying itself free again and continuing to
run.
This time, it actually remembered to cover
its face, just in time to pass Saint Nicholas
himself.
"Have you all gone mad?"
The old man had not gotten the chance to see
the creature's face himself, and was horrified
at the behavior of his friends and neighbors.
"What's gotten into you?"
The creature was preoccupied with running
and keeping its face covered, so it did not
see what happened next.
It could only hear the sound of the Santa
Claus impersonator confronting the mob, his
scandalized shouts becoming suddenly muffled,
and the troubling sound of silence followed
by the thundering stampede of crazed villagers.
The man had tried to help, but there was only
one of him, and there were so many others
intent on destroying the creature now.
So, the Shy Guy continued to run for its life,
listening to the mob just behind it, never
stopping to rest, to eat or sleep.
Whatever had filled these people with such
murderous impulse, it made them something
a little removed from human too.
They were sustained by the desire to kill,
even when their bodies should have given out
long ago.
As the creature ran, it encountered more people
that caught a glimpse of its face, that lost
themselves in the urge to destroy, and became
one with the growing horde.
The creature could no longer tell how long
it had been running, or if it would ever be
able to stop.
It was strong and seemingly invulnerable,
but how long would it be until enough people
were caught in this curse, until the mob was
big enough to swallow the creature whole?
Just when it was beginning to contemplate
giving up, lying down and letting the sea
of angry faces overtake it, a burlap bag was
thrown over its head.
It skidded to a stop, disoriented, feeling
around.
"Quick!
Get it out of here!
We need amnestics, lots of them!
These people look nuts!"
A voice barked orders, as the creature felt
hands pushing it into a small enclosed space.
The back of an SCP Foundation van, though
of course the Shy Guy didn't know that.
It could hear more voices whispering to each
other, close by.
"I've never seen anything like this...what
is this thing, anyway?"
"Stop!
Whatever you do, don't look at its face."
Now go check out “SCP-096 Origin Theories”
and “SCP-096 Tale - A Lesson In Power”
for more tales of the Shy Guy!